now that I've learned self-driving cars
aren't that far off what about
ride-sharing our companies like lyft and
uber gonna be part of the solution how
you doing all right
what are the odds you are John Zimmer
president of lyft
you got it can you drive yeah I think I
got this you don't sound very confident
anyway all right we're gonna go right
here it's great well I'm on a mission to
learn about the future of cars and I
have two kids I'm very concerned about
their future and about carbon emissions
how much does lyft think about that kind
of stuff that was one of the original
reasons why we wanted to do this the
environmental toll of having you know
just over one person in every car is
just horrible
how pie-in-the-sky is a driverless city
yeah it's very real it's the only way we
can double population in our world
cities right imagine like this
experience right now with no cars parked
in a city maybe half as many roads
because the rides themselves are more
efficient the cost will come down to the
point where you can get a ride anywhere
for under five dollars so it's like the
ultimate form of public transportation
door-to-door when you have autonomous
the economics work out that way it feels
like one of those moments in history
where we can either move forward in the
right way or we can move forward in the
wrong way because it's such a crucial
turning point the ultimate outcome
should be you know clean fuel and should
be autonomous and have the opportunity
for people to share those autonomous
rides that is a big win and electric is
a big part of that